pump the brakes there gang got a quick
poor update that stayed trashy tour is
taking over the country you know it they
don't know what to do adding shows
adding cities come out and see us live
stand-up comedy play the lay YG with the
crowd great way to introduce people to
the show come out and see the boys yeah
Gang This March we're starting in
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia then we're going to Oklahoma
City Dallas Texas Houston Texas Austin
Texas second show added there then we're
going to New Haven Connecticut as of now
it's sold out we're working on the
second show and we got Burlington
Vermont we got Tampa Florida first show
sold out second show is about halfway
sold out get those tickets Dania beats
Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Kentucky just added Cleveland
and Columbus get those tickets let's
party gang see out there on the road
yeah welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they're good to be classy yeah aren't
they just a big old piece of trash I'm
your hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at Aunt
hoodie's basement that construction
project up there continues to cause
headaches yeah and I'll tell you what
the city's up there right now they're
sniffing around that's the mayor it's
kind of Handy
man she's paying off everybody that bro
yeah
your answer sure does care about you the
addition going on in the house boy
that's going to be a brothel in a couple
of weeks I can see that right now we're
working the door Mike Carlos is coming
at you from across the table it's a
family episode just a squad this week he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he's an
international businessman and I'll tell
you what right now
best pal in the whole wide world right
there giving it to you right now my best
pal I need money give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan the only Bell also by default
I'm the worst guy the worst pal as well
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you move
oh man
the boys are in the weeds uh make sure
you rate if you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
there it's a time and obviously uh the
greatest gosh darn website sure time
www.patreon.com
go over there yeah you sign up you can
get bonus episodes ayg get episodes of
hard feeling which is the real deal the
real deal holy everybody loves it we got
the wheels up tour Vlogs up there we got
all the all the uh all the uh the goal
videos that we've hit that's all up
there it's about a bajillion hours
Disney all that stuff drunken Epcot
everything and we're heading out to the
Indianapolis 500 500 Memorial bang I get
to go in a car
driving drunk around the track
come stop me and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man oh yeah makes us all look
good works the ones works the twos
crosses the t's dots the eyes give it up
for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes hey pal just
in here at the butt crack of dawn couple
working stiffs us boys yeah early early
call time for the boys today sharking
and we were all about an hour late
in tropical and typical Dirtbag fashion
we were all late Toby's we were supposed
to be here tonight too because I'll be
there about 9 15. I'm like I'll be there
at 9 15. well Foley comes in with a 9 25
piece I think it's in here and takes a
15 minute boom boom
only I know it gets to work clocks in
takes a nice dump jammed up as we're
about to hit record man when you texted
me to ask me to get those orders I
almost went home
[__] these guys I'm out there used to be
a thing online back in the old days of
the internet the dump calculator you put
in your hourly wage it'll let you make
you let you know how much money you were
making while you were pooping yeah it
worked that was always a big thing save
it for work that's a real Dirtbag move
but I respond
yeah I worked with a lot of guys
that's crazy
I couldn't roll the dice in the car you
hit an accident on 95 you'll have an
accident on 95. get jammed up on a
Conshohocken curve they make a dollar
pay me a dime that's why I poop on
company time what's that oh man wouldn't
you work on the railroad who says that
Jesus Christ don't ever speak in rhyme
ever again that's not allowed how long
were you a chimney sweet yeah what the
[__] oh my that [__] that bothered me
yeah on a cellular level okay knock that
off I'm gonna make you cut that actually
quote rapper is like a normal person
who is that Willie Nelson what do you
think it's a meme oh man yikes just I
just thought this day couldn't get any
worse
go and start rhyming on me this early in
the morning
we apologize ladies and gentlemen he's
normally not like this
um
but I had a little uh I got a little
something what do you got a little bit
of embarrassing
uh open wound we had a cleaning lady we
we uh
uh you and the bird me and a bird really
over for a threesome I took a run at her
no
um we've been Hamming in hauling to get
one I'm paying you
um
it's been in the works we you know we
just traveled to schedule it's like one
of those things he keeps like oh we'll
do that next week you know what I mean
and we just like keep pushing it off and
pushing it off uh do you have one by any
chance no no do you have you had someone
I mean we were just talking about you
putting a commercial trash can in your
living room so yeah my place is all
jammed up yeah so we were pretty you
just moved in
I still have an unpacked we broke the
dirt from that the old apartment I still
have an unpack from Hawaii it's just
sitting on the bed that was another
thing this morning too I haven't
unpacked from Puerto Rico and I opened
up my luggage and I'm out also out um
we're jammed up I'm out of laundry
I found I found two pairs of undies in
my luggage that I didn't wear I'm
wearing my girls underwear as socks
right now
sliding around talking about a camel toe
I was I'm so jammed up on laundry at the
mom taught like jam up on all Jam uh I
almost took a dirty shirt out of my
luggage from Puerto Rico with the
thought of it's been dirty so long it's
almost clean you know what I mean like
it kind of came back around that's a
hundred percent acceptable right there's
something yeah 100 sits long enough
itself cleanses the air molecules
everything
dries up no sweat yeah right come on
it's way different than putting
something on the award two days ago yeah
I'm talking this thing's been sitting
there for about two weeks plus it has
that fresh luggage smell it's got
luggage smell Island smell as well
Island smells you know what I mean it's
not like I was in Detroit there's a
little suntan lotion on it you'd be all
right No One's Gonna know I put it on it
then you're walking around that guy just
got back from vacation I got that Island
global
now you do it man yeah dude 100 uh
something
I did something I half missed it or
didn't think that you said it
the neck was just too stretched out nah
nah never too stretched out this one was
this was one this one was rough yeah you
were jammed up huh
one so I'm just saying we got a cleaning
lady okay what's the sketch we only got
it for the first time see what she can
do see what she can do sure crushed it a
home run plus see if she knows how to
keep her mouth shut she doesn't because
she [__] put us on Instagram what she
did like before and after put on in my
bathtub I was I was Furious
we're getting needle I was devastated
we're gonna need a handle
I don't even know it what yeah she
filmed you on a story does that mean it
was so bad
I I don't know so bad it wasn't great it
was enough to be an example it was
enough for her to flex Billy Mays walks
in holy [__]
boom this guy's disgusting yeah what
yeah
unauthorized yeah I should put my social
security number on there no but I'm
saying did she ask you no my wife's all
and send it to me she's like we made the
Hall of Fame I was like oh don't [__]
tell nobody this wow
now I want to have her back because you
did a good job but I [__] hate her
I'm [__] manager she came in with a
camera crew yeah what the [__]
[__] room Raiders so she's gonna
[__] get get me in there talking my
root or something I don't need any bad
breath
hop on the John she kicks the door open
yes you [__] aired out my goddamn
Dirty Laundry she walks in right after
you were in there okay
yikes this guy yeah I'm like what the
[__] you gotta run the hay we might do
some video that's crazy crazy I'm a
public figure I gotta wrapped up keep
here can't be [__] dragging me
through the mud what the [__] showing my
nil do but she hooked it up huh yeah
it's pretty good
she didn't grow she did a great job yeah
that's a tough call uh-huh what you
banging out for ah
hmm I think 130 or something like that
okay not horrible so I think we're gonna
do maybe like once a month or once every
two three weeks or something like
whatever schedule she can uh I kind of
like the I like it especially with the
new spot you know sure you just said
you're jammed up though yeah I haven't
done it you don't like it that's the
idea of it I unload the dishwasher too
young [__] look at you I'd be getting a
little habit of that and loading the
dishwasher wiping down the countertops
yeah I mean that's you should be doing
that day to day that's just keeping
things in line we do the kitchen
probably every two days two three days
depending on the amount of cooking and
stuff like do the whole thing yeah on
the floor uh depending on Yeah clean up
the fridge
love a clean fridge we don't have a
whole lot in our fridge to begin with no
yeah we run kind of bare look at you
what would you say the ratio of doing
the counters and the dishes is to
screaming about how you were the one who
did the counters and the dishes I'm
throwing in your face yeah you'll get a
little bit of push but with the kind of
100 the rule weekend what am I doing it
for
yeah I'm not doing it for myself yeah
I'm doing it for leverage of course
these are negotiations I'm doing it so
when I wear your underwear as socks you
don't yell at me yeah this is a goddamn
proxy war what are you talking about and
move a little ground take a little yeah
trench warfare Skirmish is going on all
over the apartment a fire fight in a
bathroom right now waiting on funding
from Poland trying to straighten me out
uh I'll do I do the I take the kitchen
she takes the living room that's like
kind of like our home bases that's like
she takes care of the living room the
living room's fun fluff the pillows get
the couch yeah but not with him when you
plop down on that thing after you tidied
up the
yeah it's all right
it's a good time tighten everything up
sit down I don't like his whole rip
apart his toys in like seconds and then
that's like dude he's the stuffing from
you got an animal in there yeah the
stuffing from how do you blame the
bathroom on goddamn dog that Indian
uh yeah I mean I was this [__] this
lady that's crazy I didn't even sign a
release I didn't get a text nothing
that's like that's my intimate business
it's not cheaters
they run up on me at the store
Dirtbag
um that's uh what kind of followers does
she have I don't even know bumping
numbers I don't think so eight million
maybe if she has she has a meal but yo
tagged it kid what are you doing I can
use I could use some of the foot traffic
you know what I mean this guy's gross
but he's funny yeah he monitors what are
we doing
patreon.com Lady it's on brand yeah I
wouldn't mind it that way yeah that's uh
that's pretty wild man that's um a
cleaning lady would need an entire
documentary crew to do a before and
after of my place I could imagine ours
before and after was the bathroom was
the like the some of the tiles have got
a little jammed up yeah that happens
oh by the way I almost I almost died
this morning okay
oh man that was it was wild I slipped in
the shower that's never happened to me
before dude ever I
man thank God we have metal rings
because I was I held on to like gymnast
things
freaky in the shower I'm on the Pummel
horse the AR
foreign
the rings are metal if they were really
yeah to hold you up did I bring that
thing I'd bring the whole building down
if I grab that dude I was
dude I went I went every direct I
thought I was I one of those things
where I'm like oh I'm gonna [__]
smack my I'm gonna crack my head on
that's how a lot of people get it I know
it's crazy not that it was so scared of
the point I sat down afterwards and was
like I just to gather myself I was like
whoa whoa it was fun it was [__] up
huh I yelled I screamed it was like
a half a centimeter I would have smacked
my head on the [__] toilet and been
out like how [__]
Florentine goes in that episode of Louie
yeah that's what would have happened
sucks a trip going down some stairs
yesterday it was weird I was like
something like my brain didn't tell the
other foot to move and like I didn't I
would have felt it was a bouncer there
thank God a bouncer yeah it was at the
bottom of the steps killed that poor
bastard hey bounce right off him
gentlemen you fix your hat
gentlemen good day sir
no where was I hey somebody got to do
something about those stairs sorry for
crushing a man
he was a good boy
I'll make it right next month
somebody get him to the hospital
I'll take care of everything
[Laughter]
uh it resurfaced too but it was an old
video and then we will get into the uh
the patreon questions but I think it
might have been Philly that's why I
bring it up I don't know it was
somewhere definitely Northeast
Mid-Atlantic the guy [__] breaks down
the door looking for somebody and he's
at the wrong house a guy hit like I
guess hit a girl with a car I don't
think like murderer like whatever
and gave him a wrong address like gave
her was like oh yeah it's one two three
main street he just like made it up or
whatever nice and the dad showed up to
one two three main street to beat the
[__] [__] out of the dude and he rips
the door in the front door off the
hinges and the kids in there has no idea
what's going on how do you think he got
he's like he's Travis here he's like I
don't even know what Travis mean he got
the wrong house and then you hear the
mom from out front Henry I think he got
the wrong house this could be the wrong
house and then she comes in and he's
like I'm so sorry I work in carpentry
I'll fix the door for you because I'll
give you a good rate get us here take
the money and she goes he does win that
like yeah she's like plugging his side
business because he he takes out dude
he's ripped the door clear off the
hinges and he gives him some sort of
money and then it must be like 60 bucks
or something like that and he goes out
here take more dids he has 200 on him
that he finally gives him it's like not
even then drives car through the front
window you know I do gutters straight
yeah come to this fall so your mailbox
is leaning a little left I can shim that
for you I saw an infomercial about are
those are rip off the gutter guards
no I think they're good you better
you've been in sleazy sales before I
used to slang gutter guards yeah yeah
you moved those I didn't really move
with the side I thought you did the
windows or whatever do it all windows
Roofing sideless siding Seamless Gutters
fiber cement siding metal roofing
whatever you need I was lying to you
whatever I could do to rip you off I got
it really I didn't know you were a
gutter guard guy yeah huh uh-huh they
were expensive yeah but then you're like
hey you want to be out you want to be
climate like if I was talking to you I'd
be hey buddy what's it going to cost to
keep you off a ladder you know
I'd look at you I'd look at your bird
and be like Miss do we want to ask that
piece of [__] on on a 10-fold ladder
cleaning out the gutters it ain't worth
it I mean God forbid he falls God forbid
he falls into the house and they got to
get the homeowners involved he probably
goes down to the basement you're gonna
have to get them out of the base
uh this guy's saying for gutter guards
to be worth it you could get for the
price of the gutter guards you could get
your gutters professionally cleaned
three times a year for 20 years before
they paid for themselves that makes
sense especially with my markups
retainer
wait getting them professionally cleaned
once what three times a year three times
a year for 20 years for 20 years the
same cost as gutter guards
how are they that stupid
a lot of Bozo's out there Jesus yeah but
it's also one of those things like
you're probably pulling the commercial
we're a little too excited about them
yeah they work I think keep the leaves
out I never answered my phone afterwards
I'm thinking royalty deal here I want 10
every leaf that falls on your roof I
never answered
what's that Miss Johnson I'm going into
a tunnel
you're in our front yard
oh yeah but I think it's one of those
things where you don't you won't
schedule those things that's the that's
the problem you're never gonna schedule
them yeah you get a guy out there to
clean your [__] gutters for like 200
bucks or whatever gets up there
cut you know run and gone but I think
it's one of those things you're not
going to do it which leads to this which
leads to that which leads to leagues
whatever whatever Patty's good with that
she's got guys coming and going
no comment somebody fixing this somebody
fixing that the chimney getting clean
I'm probably like cleaning out the pipes
and stuff right
a couple guys in there banging away you
know
sometimes there's two three guys in
there
knock it off I didn't say nothing she's
good with that though so I hear it
okay
[Laughter]
what's the fun in that I'm gonna be a
couple more by the end of the week
yeah uh I got a good shirt good shirt
new shirt [__] already has a stain on
it uh-huh I got everything I get stains
on I'm aware
sucks okay let's talk about Helix
let's talk about the best night's sleep
you've ever had and sleep like you're
dead with Helix gang do yourself a favor
get over to Helix take the two minute
quiz find out how you sleep well you
sleep hot whether you sleep cold or you
sleep like a fat piece of [__] hey stop
they got plus size bedding over there
the Helix sign up includes 14 unique
mattresses including luxury model and
even mattress for the big and tall
sleeper and a husky Boy comes with a
cmitch uh like the big man said you take
the two minute sleep quiz uh me and Mima
Mima bird did it we were uh
match up with the Twilight series and I
gotta tell you we love it somebody got
shot down in one last night didn't you
got the old boot uh headaches in that
bed he looks is offering up to 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to Helix sleep.com
slash garbage this is their best offer
yet and it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts now do it twenty
percent off all mattress orders up to 20
off all mattress orders baby do it and
two free pills for our listeners Kip
this is this plate baby look at it this
is top quality product right here you
want posters on paper like a jerk off or
heavy bike yeah heavy bike metal look at
that thing dude you hang that up takes
about 20 seconds to get that up there
they use the magnets there whatever you
need it's absolutely fantastic and you
know what else too you can put your own
artwork on there sure get it up there
plus they got them licensing deals yeah
they greased a couple of Palms you got
Mandalorian you got Star Wars obviously
a little Marvel little this little that
we've got Seinfeld over here I'm a cosmo
man baby yeah shout out to him do
yourself a favor again get over to this
plate and hook yourself up with some
nice gear for the walls yeah if you can
think it display can put it on a metal
poster old posters are things of the
past you can't close any ass with a
paper poster walking over there with the
corners ripped in the thumb tank on top
of you wanna you wanna say dog ears get
your head on straight will you you want
to get some metal you want to start
smooshing get yourself a mental [__]
poster click the link in our description
to see some of our favorite disc plates
and save up to 34 baby you get 20 27 off
when you buy one or two and 34 off when
you buy three or more discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use the code
Garbage When you visit display.com
that's display.com code garbage or click
the link in the show notes do it
uh gang as you know it is that dear a
family episode I started eating laying
them down like facing forward that's all
we need lazy eating now
some of the Lazy River over in the lazy
Eaton um guys as you know what is saying
hey gosh darn Family episode when you
sign up for patreon we will answer your
garbage question audience
it's just the best way to do it uh we're
working through we got a little bit of
back there working everybody everybody's
cool nobody's complaining it's a good
time over there on the [__] page
don't take my word for it talk to a
homie if you're on the fence
talk to a [__] 10 homie and I'll let
you know I'll straighten you out
best goddamn patreon in the world fun
time yeah it's all right we love it
um all right this was this one's from
Joshua first time is it garbage you use
the wrong type of pasta for a dish
meaning what like if you have I guess
like spaghetti lasagna or something like
that you know what I mean sounds good
I'm sure that's a Midwest recipe
spaghetti I'm sure I think if you yeah
it's tough I think when you get jammed
up and I know it's in the specific ones
what do you mean like a specific if it
calls for something super specific and
you go the other end it's all the same
[__] to me I'll be honest with you okay
I always call an audible with that stuff
um
you know rigatoni this do you have penne
give me penne pennies right up the
middle though they're all kind of up to
me and they can walk in all worlds yeah
yeah the only one you can't really mess
with would be like a lasagna or a
fettuccine
something that's got fettuccine usually
needs to have those thicker noodles so
yeah but I'll tell you where you get
jammed up into the garbage realm
um and and I remember multiple times as
a little kid Patty doing this he only
got a little bit of spaghetti you throw
some angel hair in there with it you
throw a little rigatoni I've had I I've
had mixed match pasta for sure multiple
times dude I remember when angel had the
first angel hair hit I don't know if
they did a Rebrand or it just came out
in the 90s or whatever it was like I was
like what did we hit the [__] Lottery
with these angels it's like it's like
angel hair dude it's fantastic dude it's
like it was like Thriller it just
compared to [__] regular noodles oh
it [__] rock man I remember us being
on a run
my brother loved it I we were like what
the [__] they was crazy game changer
Game Changer same shitty sauce yeah same
shitty guys doing butter noodles and it
was it was really spicing those ah babe
that would I'm telling you it was my you
know what my go-to for a long time was
by when I was making it by myself back
when I was I used to make it when we
lived together in Philly I remember it
was a buttered buttered penne
a big pen in a pot throw a couple
tablespoons of [__] margarine in
there stir that up oh that's not even
butter noodles man I didn't know margin
was different until we started this show
I think I finally learned that wow that
was just butter to me I love the camera
I know I wasn't allowed to touch it what
oh I knew I wasn't allowed to touch it
why in the fridge why not you didn't
want me to touch your butt you're you're
you're not like you're touching anything
your butter substance well do I have to
get into the [__] Dr Pepper the Box
Country Crock it was a big thing of
Country Crock was all they used to make
that look so good in the commercial yeah
the white that's together it was the
wife and the husband and you never saw
them and they were [__] yapping back
and forth to each other hands see their
hands and dude the old man would [__]
slap it on there
probably praying for a heart attack I
remember her running her mouth at him
all day you know what I mean kid oh yeah
I zoned out for a second if I'm being
honest I'm not gonna lie to you
shut up I'm trying to eat my butter
trying to eat my fake butter here
I remember there was times as you know
I'm gonna be back to the recipe what are
you doing we're all hanging up we're all
hanging on by a thread here I think it
was just shredded cheese on top of that
and they called it a day what do you
pick a couple cans of cookies I was
gonna say what do you pair that with a
Coke from the [__] Exxon gas station
screamies maybe some honey roasted
peanuts for dessert those thin Planters
man if things were going well sure
those thin Planters 99 Cents man that's
cool I'm living right the amount of the
amount of cashews they sell you is nuts
it's like four cashew what are we doing
here
guys get stuck in my teeth they don't
even get down peanuts they throw at you
know I got yeah for sure
that [__] by the pound
oh they get real stingy I remember being
real bro I was 20 and I didn't couldn't
afford a full jar of pasta sauce so I
just got the pace because I thought it
was like juice concentrate like you
could like you could thin it out I
learned a heart's lesson dude
dude I gotta say [__] Matteo's in
Mateo Lane's Instagram yeah dude him
making those pastas they look so [__]
yeah he knows what he's doing it's like
it's like egg in in hey let's take egg
yolk grated cheese and like a little bit
of oregano and they put a little pasta
water in it dude it's crazy those
Italians man they know how to cook it's
not speaker goes back on butter for a
minute I remember being at my boy's
house shout out to Scott and Neil who
listen
I Scotty they were uh Neil I Can't
Believe It's Not Butter family
the first time I had ever seen it and I
again you spray it right on the roll
dude I was spraying it on a [__]
dinner and I remember me like it was
like spray paint I just remember [__]
being like I don't know what this is it
doesn't you said this like two weeks ago
you fat [__]
somebody get this
car please
I don't remember oh it was all right we
corn on the cob that
I was a game chainer for corn on the cob
mm-hmm I'm with that yeah do you anybody
in your family slice the corn off the
cob you're goddamn right my dad did it
and it was the [__] and I thought it was
the coolest thing ever and it was so
[__] good that's so funny I was so
that my stepmom did it and I remember
being like what is she I was sitting at
the dinner table for the first time
going what is she doing yeah it's it's
so how an alien would eat that food it's
so it was often like a sliver it's so
good I love it did you guys have the
corn holders the little stickies
dude they're probably still at my mom's
one or two of them sure you never had a
full set for the family though no no
there's always like an odd number yeah
one ends a four fighting over it using a
pie Fork on it shout out to the corn on
the cob though that season's gonna you
said that two weeks ago
I mentioned that and I mean it now I
mentioned food five times a year
oh God that's funny good stuff
um this one's from Joe first time long
time when your pockets are a little
tight I'm listening is it garbage to
only pump a couple gallons into your car
but stay in there extra long so it seems
like you're filling up
dude I've done that so many times no I I
never stood on airs at the gas station
oh I don't care what anybody no I would
I hang out for a little bit give me a
dollar twenty premium
I'm not an animal
some Dirtbag getting getting break again
80s 83 in there still gotta Flex on
these [__]
uh what are you filling up what is it
regular loser I got 180 of Premium over
here
um absolutely man I did that for sure I
was always I was always big too if I was
buying burnings say I had about 10 bucks
High School Bernie's were probably about
five 450 to 550. I remember when they
were 250. I remember when you could get
five with a pack of unless I've done too
many drugs no that makes sense because
when I we first started smoking like
whatever junior high or whatever
you would wait outside of [__] the
deli and ask a guy and if you gave him
five bucks
that was like you can almost get
yourself a pack you know what I mean
okay like hey you get us to straighten
yourself you don't be very close to your
own pack and that was that so that would
have been 250 they were like 275 three
bucks maybe gotcha but I would go in
with the 10 and be like oh you know
here's I mean you figure the guy inside
would just let you buy them because he
knows your dumb ass is standing out
there I think it's the plausible
diability is like I think were you
saying the charade at the at this you go
to jail for that jail no selling kid
cigs I mean I think if you're like
moving them like Henry Hill was yeah if
you've got to track their trailer from
Georgia yeah you'll get whacked I don't
think if you're buying a I think it's
probably a fine yeah maybe some
community service what do you got on
that T-Bone
fines from 300 to 1500 for the first
violation and 500 to 2500 for each
subsequent violation yeah if you're
doing that more than once that's bad
you're a pedophile yeah that's how
you're making your that's how you're
making your bones
expensive data pulling out for one last
job what about buying kids booze why
don't that jam you up that's got to be
real jail time jail time underage
drinking I mean if someone drinks and
drives and [__] kills somebody yeah
all right take it easy what do you mean
you got a lawn order going here
I got spray butter on the brain uh five
thousand bucks and or or they pull your
uh liquor license if you're that if
you're selling underage that's like if
you're at the place
oh you're so fine if you're a guy if
you're if you're the dirt bag walking in
the assembly I'll get you some beer kid
I mean also how fast and loose are you
playing with your life you're just gonna
roll the dice on the kid standing out
front of 7-Eleven what do you mean
I mean oh to buy them alcohol and who
knows what that idiot's gonna do yeah or
just like why whatever yeah never sneak
that [__] like we did I think uh you
know we never we brother an older cousin
that's where you get the booze yeah a
fake ID I mean just a guy just buying a
kid beer we never did that we never did
that we've you know we always had we
hustled yeah got a hustle yeah brother's
ID friend looks old every now and then
we if if we got a little place in
Norristown it just look the other way
everybody get on you can get put on
probation or community service huh I
don't want that guy giving back to the
community you know what I mean our old
Dirtbag I think he's already given to
the community it's true you like that
well people who buy kids boots yeah I
did back in the day man I'm not a fan of
that I'm getting it for the the brothers
the cousins the sisters the whatever way
different way different yeah than just
some random guy being like I'll get your
booze who was not intending like no
relate that's a wild call to me now the
parent that let you drink every once in
a while down the basement they were okay
but probably shifting to be that parent
this is hypothetical because you don't
have children no [__] way
never I run a tighten me either dude
I'll be down there [__] cracking
heads what are you talking about I'll
shake them first of all he'll be 88
years old they'll be stealing your pain
medication
what are you talking about
and you'll be upstairs sleeping with no
idea you're gonna be the old dad who the
oh yeah [__] Henry's dad's 180 years
old he's dead I think we're about to go
up and put a [__] finger under your
nose to make sure you're breathing
now Patty was obviously no not that at
all she'd [__] ruin you what he is
dead yeah
my mom it was always suspect
of the house he hung out too much at
yeah
drink it up there and I would always get
yeah Ma that's what we're doing I always
would give my buddy's dad a little bit
of attitude when she saw him at the
lacrosse games and stuff
they're always over your house why
[Laughter]
I'm not a huge [__]
I don't know you seem like a nice lady I
just met you and you're screaming at me
on a Sunday morning
but
I don't know if she I think she was just
more oblivious to a lot of stuff and or
didn't oblivious I mean come on
um I was running rackets out of that
joint but then also at a certain age
like my family you know we're heavy
booze bags so it's like at 16 you hide
it right at 16 you're not allowed to
drink at a family party everybody knows
you're sure oh it's we're leaving early
we're going here 19 you stink one or two
18 19. 20 you're making out with your
cousin yeah 18 or 19 you're fine
whatever if you're in college that's all
right so that's how my family looks at
it if you're enrolled in college or you
join a union you're gonna have an ice
cold beer at the end of the day that's
how they look oh yeah sure you know what
I mean if you're [__] hanging
sheetrock or digging ditches you can
have a beer come come quitting time pass
your joint fitness test
if you know how to pack and pour a joint
on soil pipe I'll let you have a shot of
whiskey uh this is probably more uh hard
feelings or patreon but um
subtle plug
no I just feel you guys seem cool I'll
tell you
all right I'll talk to losers like I
just know I shouldn't be running my
mouth yeah that's really what I'm saying
but I'm about to anyway of course
um we we were she called your mom a
[__] for four minutes no I didn't I
love you Patty
um we uh it was always instilled in us
very early now me we started drinking
you know earlier than I think most of
our other extended family members all
right you and your brother yeah so we
had a little more experience with it and
everybody has one or two where you got
so [__] up and embarrassed yourselves
you know what I mean
in front of the family or friends no
luckily that happened to us oh you
learned it behind closed doors sure and
you just did it in front of your friends
you know what I mean like what the [__]
was wrong
couple of cousins [__] slipped up
yeah that was always my biggest fear
don't [__] embarrass yourself in a
[__] family party yeah I had I had a
cousin remain nameless
every dude
yeah he listens and he can handle his
stuff I think he
I don't know what was that I don't know
if there was extracurricular activities
involved or whatever I did get drunk at
a wedding where I was crying on the way
home but I don't think anybody saw that
why uh I loved your mean
I thought they pull the hors d'oeuvres a
little early
they said there would they said there'd
be more finger foods
yeah
the girl with this girl of that Jesus
coming back
she said she'd be right back
yeah they hold on to those real tight at
weddings the [__] bacon wrap scallops
you get like one lap at them and they're
sprinting I mean we've mentioned it
before if I'm at a wedding where a not
all I'm not friends a lot of people like
if I'm a plus one or it's a little bit
more extended and I don't have like a
[__] real Circle to hang with I'll
I'll grab a couple of bevies post up
right by that door where they come out
snag them they they know they can
[__] I'm like the garbage disposal if
they're trying to go take a sick break
and they got they got five little
cocktail weenies on there sure I know
they bring them over to me look just
brush them onto the table Yeah I just
drank too much I [__] like completely
drank too much and for some reason got
emotional in the car and was bawling my
eyes out
my dad was driving my mom was in the
front and me and my brother in the back
I was like probably 25 at the time oh
but nobody saw it that was in private
that was that's Foley business we always
kept our mouth shut up oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah my family won't fist fight each
other and then just be like in the
morning but yeah he passed the orange
juice
sweep that [__] under the rug but I have
seen a couple of situations where
people got too drunk and it was a scene
and then discussed for several months
amongst the fans sure that happens as
well as well the Irish are real gossipy
yeah what's up
um but my cousin got all banged up I
want to say it was at Thanksgiving and
he came back and there's a long dining
room table with a platter of like dinner
rolls or something and he he's all
[__] up and he threw them all like he
took the big Trails like a big serving
tray and threw the rolls off and then
sat on the end of this amongst mixed
families not not intermediate or not not
just his family yeah all the Aunts
Uncles even a couple of guests a couple
of like you know family friends like uh
Uncle Mark that's not your uncle type
thing you know what I mean were they
pillsbury's that would have killed him I
don't know but he you son of a [__] he
must there must have been it hits you
every once in a while well he got on the
edge of the [__] dining room T sat on
the edge of the dining room table people
facing out and started driving the bus
with the serving trade dude going all
aboard he was about 17. that's just a
good bit
let's get the hat on
that's all right he's doing the door and
[__]
so now I'm driving the bus Kim's got
chops he's a method actor this one yeah
it happens you get damn happy that's
like one step away from the guy trying
to do the the tablecloth trick all right
everybody be still
[Laughter]
I swear to God I could do this it looks
easy
you quit is there anything more trashy
than that there's not dude if you've
ever tried it in Atlanta I don't know
how to do it
you think that guy gets laid at the end
of the night dude it takes a lot of
balls it's a goddamn [__] catering
company they got overhead here buddy I'm
trying to play [__] David Copperfield
man okay let's talk about kenzuri
attention short Kings
attention short Kings we got a [__]
new kid on the Block here and it's
consory yep and they put the insoles in
the shoe give you a little bit of a leg
up the broads are wearing heels uh-huh
why not Flex a little bit yeah give you
about 2.8 inches you look like LeBron
walking around yeah they make the shoes
that make you two point inches taller
without anyone knowing baby they're
stylish they're comfy and they're not
old man shoes they have styles for every
occasion smart casual sporty you name it
the insoles are built into the shoe so
no one knows you're getting a boost
there you go the brand is also hidden
the brand is also hidden on the shoes
and the packaging so it are it'll be our
Dirty Little Secret you don't need
everybody knows knowing your business
you know he's like Nick Nolte walking
around guys life is short and you don't
have to be baby you know what I mean you
got girls wearing Spanx dudes wearing
spangs to look different if you're a
short king throw a parodies on
their eyebrows done the baldi's getting
their hair done do yourself a favor get
a leg up yeah baby walk around with your
head held high your chin up in the air
and [__] start dunking on these fools
on top of these [__] on top of 30 off
the site our listeners get an extra
exclusive 15 off discount at kenzuri.com
and use the code garbage that's a total
of 45 off your order that's code garbage
at kanzori.com that's
c-o-n-z-u-r-i.com code garbage when I
want to get high I put on a pair of
Consortium I'm back to the show get
yourself laid boys yeah the liquor just
hit you I think like growing up too it
just sometimes just [__] it hits you
weird yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like
learning a language you go ahead I don't
go there you know it's a it's a learning
process yeah you know you get bit by
something you don't go back whatever
whatever
um all right let's see here uh
uh this one's from Douglas ten dollar
homie never have one right is it garbage
or be a pharmacist who catches heaters
on his lip
oh stingers
yeah herpes hey that's a dude if you're
going if I'm going to try to get a
z-pack and the guy's got [__] a
couple of [__] hurt bangers on his
lip I'm I'm switching pharmacies sucking
on raspberries
um it's I'll I'll just say I'm not
[__] on the fact you get them you
get them okay I catch heaters you you
can't not notice them and you go sure
you question a little in your it's just
they're they're so blatantly obvious
where you go oh come on it looks scummy
call out I just have to wait a sick day
I used to wait tables with them oh I I
would I'd believe I'd you put this in a
box and then throw it out for me please
put my herpes
get this to go right into the trash can
by any chance I want 10 off of that
thing looking at me
um I'm Henry this is Frank
he's trading he's shadowing me today
and we'll be your Waiters
I'm Henry this is Franco we'll be your
Waiters
he's gonna take your drink order
we think we'll be right back with more
bread we do a few specials tonight Frank
would like to tell you tell them Frank
one's a dirty hooker stay away
um
as a person who gets them uh-huh yeah
it's a tough look I you know yeah it's
obviously I can't I don't judge but you
can't not help you like now you judge a
little bit you start making some
assumptions yeah it's tough but it's
nice what it is I understand so many
people have it people are you're born
with it
maybe it's Maybelline
maybe it's herpes
is he born maybe he's born with it maybe
he's a [__] scumbag
maybe maybe he got caught kissing the
town bike you know what I mean
yeah the town bike because everybody's
had a ride
[Laughter]
uh hold on okay but for some reason the
pharmacist would be you expect him to be
of a higher cloth if the plumber came
over to fix the pipes I wouldn't care
that guy's touching things that are
going in my mouth
I don't know if that's my I don't know I
I'm more okay with that I think
pharmacist is supposed to be of a higher
Prestige they stand a foot above you
he's gonna still do it right there pop a
[__] Valtrex do you know right
straighten yourself go to the [__]
Mainframe buddy what are you doing
he got the plug
[__] get high on your own Supply dude
I don't want to be looking at this
showing firecrackers
that's a good question man that's great
server I used to that's tough yeah I
used to be like [__] man this sucks I
couldn't call out needed the money I had
a perk addiction
that's addicted to painkillers at the
time
um it's the name of your autobiography
herps and perks
the h4ley story
uh this one great name this one's from
Terry
uh
uh first time long time how do you say
illegal is it illegal hold on is it
illegal illegal or illegal
I'm uh hold on stop
illegal illegal
I say illegal oh it's illegal it's you
that would be uh I would say like that's
illegal
all legal that is illegal illegal is the
proper way to say illegal it's illegal
yeah yeah I'm [__] I got herpes
I love these ones because I'd imagine
all the people driving in their cars
everybody there's there's hundreds of
thousands of people going illegal
illegal illegal
illegal all legal illegal no it's it
okay I know I'm saying I say illegal yes
yeah you're trash we're both trying I
know a lot of people have been [__]
really jamming me up on my words
recently mean
I say cousin I know
c u s i n t cousin your cousin my cousin
T oh Hardy yeah yeah yeah
hard tea on the boys yeah
um all right this one's from friend ten
dollar dildo haven't had one in my ass
yet okay uh
hire that man well this guy is a freak
is it garbage to marry your favorite
stripper my wife of eight years was a
dancer when we met now runs her own
small business
something hot about it uh yeah hey if it
works it works I mean you were able to
pull off what every dude thinks they can
do you landed the stripper every guy
who's ever stepped into another fact
that you had a favorite
shows a little bit of Trish yeah on you
yeah which I respect but you got her you
got her
pretty good right I mean every dude
walks into a strip club finds a stripper
and they we think it's it's the [__]
you know the lizard brain thing maybe um
maybe she really does like me every guy
out there has fallen prey to it you know
what I mean and she don't when you're
out of there get in the car we just
drive start a new life somewhere me and
you yeah it's all we need
yeah that's crazy man let's stop at the
house and grab you some clothes
because you're dressed like a hussy
can't be wearing that at the gas station
can't be dealing with that small town
America honey uh
uh I'm gonna stick out like a sore thumb
in Toledo
um
that's awesome man [__] shout out to
him yeah that's great check out those
wedding photos
what you guys dance to
what's up
yeah man that's all right good for him
[__] love that's a win love to see it
I respect it yeah I've never heard of
anybody actually marry I mean you know
the date to hook up a little bit but
Landon won for good and getting her out
of the game she's now owns her own small
business there you go no daddy daughter
dance to that wedding
[Music]
coming to the altar next cinnamon
that's terrible Toby you don't know that
got a hunch maybe she just had the goods
and wanted to shake it which I respect
yes send us some photos what are we
doing
for scientific purposes
there was a couple of jeans at that
wedding though I'll tell you that and a
bike or two parked out front oh I would
imagine I'm sure motorcycle yeah a
couple of hogs out there
what do you think I meant 10 speed no I
don't know why I don't think anybody
thought you meant 10 speed
there was somebody I don't think
stripper didn't think Huffy somebody in
a leather vest
was that that way yeah yeah probably
which would be the toughest of all looks
I wonder what he does
he might have a couple of bucks going
there throwing around get her attention
because it ain't easy to get these these
strippers attention I'll tell you what
he does do [__] get laid Yeah this
kid's all right this guy puts in work
pulling strippers come on
yeah yeah
shout out to him what's his name Fran
Franny I think I deleted it by accident
uh yeah I believe for him
um I like it all right this one's from
Dr shrimp stick 4 000. you ever tell the
cab driver to pull over so you can throw
up
like a gentleman uh most people just
puke in the [__] back of the car man
yes that's a [__] gentleman's move
I've never had that I've puked out the
back door not while moving like because
you're typically you figure in the city
so you're gonna catch the light you
catch the oh I don't like he's like are
you okay sir I'm like yeah I'm good I
just need it I sneezed
at last beer was all foam that's what I
tell them
you know a Coke guy
he's showing through McDonald's real
quick
a little base going a little base yeah
that's uh yeah I was a puker I had like
a bad gag reflex and I would drink so
much so quick and I go out for a heater
and catch a hiccup and then it's [__]
your bad news I'm not that bad with the
with the booze and the puking College I
drank College was bad I drank a bottle
pretty close to a bottle of Pinnacle
right vodka who you P Diddy yeah it was
P Diddy's right now he was hamster no he
was uh no he was a rock that's a rock
all in my bottle that's what I was I
think it was Ciroc yeah I drank a bottle
for some reason for a while I was on a
big vodka and grapefruit kick
and after [__] 19 of them just
tough luck of pukes kill me kill me that
was when you learned as a kid you didn't
know anything so you'd get I'll get me a
handle of vodka or whatever we'll do
screwdrivers [__] you know 14
screwdrivers later laying off of
somebody's like guest bedroom like [__]
things on the way up somebody's kissed
me I can see that bed oh yeah I can see
that bed it has like uh like floral fall
colors and like Ruffles on them yeah
there's no TV in there remember that
room oh [__] uh-huh jammed up a clock
that's wrong yeah it was like three
degrees colder oh yeah it's over the
garage or something I hated those guest
rooms like that yeah that [__] sucked
uh
um
but let's see here uh
this one's from Chris new patreon
dimebagtramp here haven't had one red
what is the trashiest non-swimware to
swim in
I have mine I think
and it's not jeans
is it cargo pants
no because those are active at least
don't say basketball shorts no that was
my bathing suit up until I don't know a
few years ago
sweatpants shorts
that I've done it those things get heavy
they're not supposed to get wet it's
like SEAL training cut off jean shorts
I'll give you that's kinda you know if
you're doing something in a lake or
whatever you're rope swinging something
that's a there's no reason sweatpants
shorts should be wet yeah I got you turn
into like 180 pounds I'll give that to
you I'd say the sweatpants short as well
the cut off jean shorts man you felt
alive I had [__] I had two or three
favorite pair of cut off jean shorts
that I wore like two months every summer
like you know like sophomore year junior
year senior man
all right never getting that back nope
it was a good time a lot of dungarees to
cover you now
uh this one's from Toby cam dong blowing
budget I don't I don't know uh recently
invested 10 homie is it garbage to buy
cars based solely on their name having
Uncle Jimmy who for a period of time
exclusively bought GMC jimmies
I mean that car stinks yeah I had the
worst well in high school my mom had the
worst Jimmy the Bravada
oh yikes dude this thing was that the
wagon or the minivan no it was like a
smaller Jimmy
it was this we had a white one a white
what Jimmy yeah yeah the Jimmy was good
no they weren't they were compared to
the Bravada they my dad told me they did
something where the bottom was too heavy
it was there was too much like axle or
frame or something like that and didn't
match up that car sucked balls this
thing dude this thing stunk
that's what my mom was whipping around
in
yikes yeah the Bravada man straighten
her out I think it was I think it was
leather in the front and cloth seats in
the back
we had the half and half
that's so trashy imagine they were
buying power windows just only on the
driver's side
that's like they were buying they would
that's a bit of a tough look or you just
you know where you're at when the power
when the power seats only in the driver
yeah I thought you know where you stand
you're reaches through pull the ejection
seat and trying to get back
although I enjoy the bar better because
it's quicker you do
so I'm sitting there like a gerbil fat
guy I love that I get it just right no I
like the bar the bar I gotta go down a
little bit a little bit lower
sometimes if I'm driving and my legs
started hurting I raise up the front a
little bit
yeah it's a whole thing it's a pulmonary
embolism I think driving in your life
trying to prevent that science behind
that sure uh this one's from lady is it
garbage to bring your own putter to mini
golf
that's a tough look
you you're gonna be a real stickler
about the rules
just trying to she's trying to get a
couple of [__] whacks and and grab a
Twist coat I know take it easy watch out
for that windmill the slopes to the
right got a caddy
get the [__] yeah man get the range
finder out I mean it's about three yards
if you want to talk sportsmanship
it's got to be an even playing field you
gotta roll the dice with the [__]
rentals I think if a kid wants uh this
is how I did what I would never let [__]
what let the kid use a good putter is
that what you're gonna say no if they
say the kid golfs if the
seven-year-old's into golfing then I'd
go yeah he wants to have fun and like
be competitive at I don't care about a
kid yeah I'll give him that all right
you know what I mean like he can do it
you're a grown man though
yeah absolutely not if you're I mean you
shouldn't be [__]
playing mini golf by yourself as a grown
man sure if you take one with your kids
that's even weirder when I go with the
nieces and nephews at a cousins or
whatever I just hit it a couple of times
and walk around with them let them
[__] do that [__] yeah I'll take an
eight on this one you're at the beverage
Court
give me an eight give me a Snowman Play
We're the rules here kids
now who wants a chili dog
I just found out the twins have bowling
balls oh that's bad they're boys yeah
wow that's a tough look I don't know I
always wanted one though I'll tell you
that
I we used to hang out at the bowling
alley in summers at the Brunswick Zone
on Tuesdays in the summer they did
dollar games and dollar beers and we
like put like oh there's probably 21 20
good time and you think I gotta get a
ball whatever they're like 200 oh I
don't know whatever you know and you're
like oh that one's cool but like
never would ever pull the [__]
trigger do they bowl that much they've
been bowling they've putting up scores
like on numbers what's a bowling ball
run I don't know 200 bucks 300 bucks
probably could be expensive I mean for a
custom job
about 200. yeah what about you want to
get the rose put in the middle big
earned McCracken let them know
rather than like Jesus
all right this was from Jesse have you
ever contacted a major food manufacturer
to get your money back for a defective
or tainted product example I once got a
can of Frito Lay cheese dip that was
separated and watery when open after
filling out an extensive form on their
website and submitting several photos
back of the product I've received about
ten dollars worth of coupons in the mail
several weeks later
that sounds like something Patty would
do I think he'd go to the [__]
letters oh she would no she would go
right back to the grocery store and make
them you made good [__] yeah okay yeah
that I get she's maybe returned two
three things at a grocery store but not
really so much you know what I mean she
makes the right choices
checks it out
um you can't check the inside of a jar
thing of cheese sure sure sure yeah I
wasn't I wasn't [__] on uh on the
question
um but it got me thinking
when we were kids
if you sent anything to like Double
Bubble
hey I love your gum
they'd send you a [__] like two cases
of gum sure I heard we never did that
was a good time we did that once or
twice baseball cards or something like
that they send you a little something
something yeah we never got you we were
the mail to me is a kid
oh you you thought you had to get like
authorization I'd be like Mom can we
mail how are you talking about no like
we know I never mailed I never said
anything here's letters to Santa Claus
yeah
it was like they didn't like people
knowing your head smaller
get I can't do it best I can best I can
do is a basketball
I feel like my parents never wanted
people like knowing where we lit it was
like don't let anybody know nothing
about nothing that's what gave me my
paranoia it'd be nice people would call
I'm not here who is it don't answer it'd
be nice if they would have sent her the
actual things the coupons is one thing
but I don't hate that to be honest with
you that's a fun thing you throw it out
there and then a couple weeks later you
forget about it oh I'll give you that
kick the can down there but then yeah I
don't know just not a coupon guy either
and only just because I dealt with so
many crazy coupon people when I was a
cashier at a supermarket that was when
Extreme Couponing dropped so it was like
every [__] Joe Schmo thought they
were like you know flipping houses like
you know what I mean I can do that
everybody was coming in with
manufacturer coupon store coupons yeah
hey we have to double we match any
manufacturer coupon up to a dollar this
one didn't double like [__] chaotic
was it a nickel I'll get an ankle
so I'm spackling did you get trouble for
that
yeah yeah I got in trouble for a lot of
stuff yeah but I just told you I was
ripping people off of gutters too I
wasn't playing by this somebody came in
and it was a nickel and you said I'll
give you the next it was like 35 cents
difference or I was like oh this is
ringing up a dollars it should be 75
cents I go what is it a quarter I was
jammed that was like Thanksgiving Day or
something you probably you probably had
a sandwich getting cold somewhere I had
to go get my soft pretzels from the
bakery
all right we gotta wrap it up though
gang gang what a fun episode we'd love
you to death we're out there on the road
pickies are moving quick I'm gonna tell
you that right now you snooze you lose
so do yourself a favor grab some ticks
bring the squad and come out and see us
we love you to death and we will see you
next week peace